If there is one thing fans like more than
watching their favorite movies, it's ranking
every aspect of them.
"The Batman," the latest in a storied history
of Batman movies, provides fresh fodder for
fans.
So the real question is: Pattinson vs. Bale.
Who really played the better Batman?
The Dark Knight has been played by so many
actors at this point that you would be hard-pressed
to find a person who doesn't have some sort
of ranking for the collection of actors and
their respective portrayals.
It used to be that a favorite Batman could
be separated by generation.
It's now more apt to compare Batman performances
based on intention and tone than anything
else, especially when you consider the thematic
valleys between, say, George Clooney in "Batman
& Robin" and Ben Affleck in "Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice."
Some of the performances, however, are easy
to compare, arguably the two closest being
Christian Bale and Robert Pattinson.
Bale portrayed Batman in Christopher Nolan's
famed "Dark Knight" trilogy, while Robert
Pattinson debuted his version of the caped
crusader in this year's "The Batman."
Both depictions of Batman examine the early
years of the vigilante through a lens far
more grounded in reality than other more fantastical
comic book movies.
But which actor do fans think did a better
job bringing a darker Dark Knight to life?
Director Christopher Nolan's "Batman Begins"
became one of the most critically acclaimed
comic book films ever when it was released
in 2005, winning near-universal praise from
both critics and fans.
Fans have continued to show support for Bale,
with the actor even being voted the best Batman
in a poll this year from GameSpot.
Out of more than 290,000 votes, Bale received
66% of the support as the best Batman against
competitors Ben Affleck, Adam West, and Michael
Keaton.
While Nolan's "The Dark Knight" is the high
mark for many fans regarding "Batman" movies,
some are already declaring Robert Pattinson
and "The Batman" superior even though the
film was only just released.
"I'm vengeance."
Like Bale, Pattinson has also won over critics,
with "The Batman" currently standing at an
85% "fresh" rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Critic Christy Lemire drew comparisons to
Robert De Niro in "Taxi Driver" in her review
for RogerEbert.com.
She said:
"This is Travis Bickle in the Batsuit, detached
and disillusioned.
[He's] not just prepared but hungry to explore
this figure's weird, dark instincts."
There is plenty to compare when looking at
the performances of Christian Bale and Robert
Pattinson in their respective "Batman" projects.
Both actors turned to edgy adaptations of
the character after careers building respectable
performances in challenging pieces.
Bale performed in movies like "American Psycho"
and Pattinson more recently with indie films
such as "The Lighthouse."
Both have also earned similar praise for their
debut portrayals of Batman, a character each
shows as a brooding figure at the beginning
of a journey of possible addiction to his
vigilante persona.
Between the two, however, Bale is the favorite.
This may not always be the case, but with
three highly praised movies under his belt,
Bale has earned more faith with audiences.
"What the hell are you?"
"I'm Batman."
Next to the recent GameSpot poll crowning
Bale as the fans' favorite by a wide margin,
there is also a 2020 survey similarly finding
Bale on the top of the Batman heap.
While "The Batman" has earned plenty of praise
too, Bale's movies remain more universally
liked, with "The Dark Knight" touching 94%
with critics and audiences alike on Rotten
Tomatoes.
Even "The Dark Knight Rises" earned higher
marks with critics than "The Batman."
While Pattinson has not dethroned Bale, it
should be noted that "The Batman" is only
his first film, and he hasn't been included
in many public polls.
If the reviews are any indication, though,
Pattinson could soon be replacing Bale for
many as their preferred Dark Knight.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.